[Música]
vamos ahora con revista de prensa y ya
nos acompañan el estudio Marta Moya
bienvenida Hola Rosa muy buenos días
Genaro se me hace saludarte Sí
igualmente no nuestros compañeros
bromeaban que podíamos hacer el meme de
spider-man no
bueno Marta empezamos con el tema que
fue bueno que ayer ocupó muchos
titulares y hoy también tiene sus Ecos y
es todavía un misterio hablamos de estas
imágenes de explosiones impactando
contra el edificio del kremlin no Así es
rosa vamos a reconstruir un poco todo lo
que pasó ayer porque el mediodía hora de
Moscú la prensa y sobre todo la agencia
de noticias estás muy afiliada al
kremlin publicaba un vídeo que ya había
sido rodado por varios canales de
Telegram en el que vemos a dos drones
impactando contra el kremlin justo y que
los detienen justo antes de impactar
contra el edificio del ejecutivo ruso
los vídeos salen a mediodía pero los
ataques ocurren a las 2 de la mañana por
tanto hay un impasse muy grande de
tiempo entre el impacto y entre en que
esto se hace viral y empieza a circular
por todos los medios de comunicación
además ocurre en el kreming que es uno
de los edificios más fortificados de
Rusia y ahí estaba no estaba Putin pero
dice las autoridades que fue un ataque
intencionado para terminar con la vida
del mandatario ruso algo que kiev niega
porque Rusia ataca directamente a
Ucrania también escuchábamos ayer que el
presidente ruso medgedev decía que había
que acabar físicamente con volodimir
zelemsky después de este ataque Rosa Sí
aquí estábamos viendo las imágenes
detrás tuyo Marta y Bueno muchísimas
incógnitas no y una de ellas es
precisamente porque se revelan esos
videos en ese momento pero bueno ya
vamos a llegar a eso ahora repasamos los
principales titulares de la prensa rusa
al respecto empezamos por RT sí RT
recoge las declaraciones Rosa del
Ministerio de exteriores de María
zajarova que acusa a quién de lo
ocurrido pero dice que los autores
intelectuales de todo este ataque contra
el kremlin no son otros sino los países
de la otan además dice zaharova que
estas acciones no van a quedar impunes y
que es un ataque agravado porque es
contra la sede del gobierno y contra
Vladimir Putin sostiene esa jaroba
textualmente que este ataque es una
muestra de especial cinismo de las
autoridades ucranianas neonazis Bueno un
discurso muy en la línea de lo que hemos
oído Pues a lo largo de más de un año de
guerra pero vamos con sputnik el sputnik
que recoge que desde el gobierno
condenan textualmente los métodos
terroristas empleados por kiev además
dice sputnik que los presuntos ataques
ucranianos sólo son un episodio más de
la escalada ucraniana terrorista se
suman al ataque al puente de crimen
octubre de 2020 a las ofensivas contra
infraestructura militar en varias
regiones rusas fronterizas con Ucrania y
a otras acciones de Sabotaje Además
desde la justicia dice sputnik ya han
abierto una causa penal por terrorismo
por lo ocurrido ayer si Marta y ataques
que también tuvieron lugar el pasado fin
de semana no a pesar de que pues kiev
tampoco los reivindica vamos ahora con
riano Bosch el ryanovovosti recoge las
declaraciones rosas del portavoz del
ejecutivo de dimitripes que personaliza
a occidente en Estados Unidos y acusa
directamente a Washington de lo ocurrido
dice a menudo los objetivos en sí mismos
no están determinados por kiev sino por
Washington y sostiene que esta
información de que Washington está
detrás de los Data que es al kremlin
viene dada por parte de los servicios
rusos aunque no emite más detalles
pescott bueno veremos Marta Porque al
margen de quien haya estado detrás de
esto sobre todo lo que importa es como
Rusia va a reaccionar no ante este
episodio sea quien sea pues que tenga la
autoría y cerramos con bedomochi este
medio ruso bastante Imparcial digamos Sí
y el bedomory no hace declaraciones
explícitas sobre lo ocurrido sino que
retrata que tras lo ocurrido ayer en
Moscú el alcalde de la urbe cerró el
espacio aéreo para el vuelo de drones
una medida a la que se han sumado
también desde las desde la alcaldía de
San Petersburgo y casi otro medio
centenar de urbes en toda Rusia Marta
ahora veamos cómo abordan esta cuestión
los medios independientes de Rusia Sí
Rosa hemos destacado el vitrosca que es
un medio independiente ruso que destaca
algunas rarezas no sobre todo este
ataque el primero porque los primeros
reportes pasan a las dos y media de la
mañana Sin embargo Pues todo esto no
sale a la luz hasta el mediodía ruso hay
12 minutos entre el impacto del primer
dron y el segundo dron sin embargo las
defensas aéreas no actúan entre en ese
intervalo de tiempo y además la
disposición de las cámaras está situada
en edificios gubernamentales por lo
tanto hay toda una incógnita respecto a
y además este medio sostiene en
exclusiva que el gobierno ruso ha
cancelado los desfiles por el día de la
victoria en 21 ciudades
exclusiva no bueno sin duda Seguiremos
lo que pase la semana que viene con el
día de la Victoria vamos a ver lo que
titula el kiev post al respecto por el
lado ucraniano no sí el reitera que kiev
se desvincula del ataque Y además que
Rusia se ha inventado el ataque para
justificar sus próximos movimientos
militares en Rusia cita analistas que
dicen que aunque Ucrania tiene la
capacidad de llevar a cabo estos ataques
no es realista que que vaya perpetrado
un ataque de estas características y
además critica los sistemas de defensa
rusos aéreos que si finalmente lograron
en llegar al edificio más fortificado de
Rusia pues hago está fallando eso dice
el que claro completamente y además y
como como bien decías Marta hubo este
este tiempo no de más de 10 minutos
entre una explosión y otra y tampoco se
activó ninguna defensa que impidiera
pues el segundo impacto bueno Marta
pasamos ahora a otros medios
occidentales empezamos por el New York
Times Sí Rosa el New York Times dice que
venga de donde venga el ataque el
gobierno ruso quería que esto se viera
en todo el mundo es una publicación
inusual que hizo el Gobierno también en
su página web acusando a kiev de lo
ocurrido y que esto no lo había hecho en
ataques anteriores como el asesinato a
daria dubina en agosto o el puente de
crimea en octubre o incluso la muerte de
un bloguero Pro ruso el mes pasado y
Marta Qué dice la bbc rápidamente nos
vamos quedando sin tiempo la bbc dice
que el ataque es vergonzoso para el
kremlin porque Putin es uno de los
líderes más protegidos del mundo y el
acceso al kremlin está siempre
fortificado y lleno de controles y que
si Rusia toma represalias
veremos una escalada con consecuencias
todavía desconocidas claro Marta Porque
este es un contraargumento no para los
que usan este ataque de ser de bandera
de propia bandera Bueno qué dice Sky
news Sky news dice que con este ataque
Rusia puede reforzar sus ataques a
occidente y kiev y que también puede ser
Útil para reducir las celebraciones por
el día de la Victoria que recordemos
celebra la victoria de Rusia frente a la
Alemania nazi dice que por cómo se filmó
el ataque se desatan un montón de
teorías de la conspiración pero que
puede servir también para que los rusos
se alineen con su gobierno y el gobierno
pueda seguir movilizando a gente ante
una contraofensiva ucraniana y para
cerrar Marta Toronto Stars el Toronto
Star cita a una experta en política
possoviética María popova que dice que
Estados Unidos ya advirtió a Ucrania en
febrero de 2022 que no atacará a Moscú
por tanto es difícil que quiebre esté
detrás de esta operación dice popova que
puede ser todo una operación de bandera
falsa por los orquestada por los
servicios de seguridad ucraniana para
justificar una escalada ante la tan
esperada contraofensiva Marta pues
muchísimas gracias por todo este repaso
de este tema tan misterioso gracias